there were four levels of learning the
first level is called being
unconsciously incompetent when you first
start doing something you know so little
about it you basically know nothing the
next level is becoming consciously
incompetent that means that you're like
Jesus Christ I don't know anything
you're like I've is this does that does
that sewing strategies they also get I
don't know them that's the next level
next level above that is called being
consciously competent consciously
confident means that you're good at
something but you can't really do it
with your eyes closed yet your guru
requires all your focus and your mental
energy you can't tie your shoe and have
a conversation at the same time that's
when you're consciously competent is
Ling it requires all your conscious
focus the next level above that is
called being unconscious competence and
that means when you're really really
great at something you can do it without
thinking about it and the only way to
get from conscious competence to
unconscious competence is through
practice there's no other way by
drilling it into your head again and
again and again and again and again
until your brain just clicks and all of
a sudden using the unconscious part of
your mind which is infinitely more
powerful than your conscious mind the
reason that most people are not
successful but not wealthy is not
because they set their goals too high
and miss them because it's too low and
you hit them and you get caught up in
the average daily struggle of averages
and mediocrity but the idea here is you
want to set the goals just above your
comfort zone and think about your goals
right now how do you set them you're
setting them very low and hitting them
and are you setting goals that don't
inspire you they not the sort of goals
that make you jump out of bed in the
morning make you want to go to work for
yourself to secure the future not just
for you but for your family so you have
to compromise
acquiesce to anybody unless you love
them unless you want to that's freedom
you know money is just a mechanism to
get there you just watched two amazing
clips from jordan belfort take the next
three minutes to sit quietly and think
about how you can apply them to your
business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]